Connor flowers the brother of Southern
Charm star Olivia flowers has died he
was 32 years old
[Music]
several of Olivia's co-stars shared
their condolences on social media Leva
Bonaparte writing on Instagram that as
friends of the flowers family they have
been asked to stand around them and ask
others to respect their need for privacy
so they can grieve the loss of their
loved one Olivia's close friend and
co-star Taylor Ann green shared a
similar sentiment quote privacy is
number one please keep in mind that this
is a heartbreaking and grieving time for
them Taylor added that sending the
family love and prayers as they continue
to heal is the only appropriate thing to
do in this moment
thank you
page six received a statement from the
Charleston County coroner indicating
Conor died on January 30 at his home on
the Isle of Palms outside of Charleston
the manner and cause of death are
pending and the local police department
is investigating as for Southern Charm
Alum Thomas Ravenel he released a
heartbreaking tribute too noting that
Conor died just 10 days shy of his 33rd
birthday words can't rightfully describe
how rare and remarkable you were and
adds he will be terribly missed
Olivia appeared to be close to her
brother sharing family photos on
Instagram over the years
what's up MTV I'm Connor I'm Olivia
welcome to Dallas Texas it's our crew
let's go inside and check out the fun we
got going on they also appeared on an
episode of MTV Cribs together as
teenagers
I play golf a lot so golf flag bunch of
good names in the game I used to play
golf three or four times a week I don't
really get much Valentine anymore with
school and all but I try to play about
once a week or so the reality star has
yet to speak out publicly about her
brother's death
foreign
[Music]